Hassan Nasrallah had reiterated that all
American military assets across this
region are now in danger that they are
now targets this was a point that he
made several times throughout his speech
but he did draw an important distinction
mr. nasrallah went on to say I want to
be very clear we do not mean American
citizens or Nationals
there are many Americans in our region
we don't mean to attack them and it is
wrong to harm them attacking us
civilians anywhere serves Trump's
interests he also went on to say the
Americans will withdraw from our region
humiliated in disgrace
and he also believe he also went on to
say the minute Americans start seeing
their sons in coffins
the Americans and President Trump will
know they lost the war and the region I
think one of the more fascinating and
telling things about the speech by mr.
nasrallah which lasted well over an hour
is the fact that he continued to speak
about Iraq that really seemed to be one
of the main themes when it came to his
remarks and many of his remarks lined up
quite a bit with what a talks a prime
minister caretaker Prime Minister Abadi
was telling Parliament his speech was
happening at the same time as mr.
Nasrallah's you had both lead at both of
these men urging the u.s. to withdraw
from Iraq and this really seemed to
suggest a very coordinated effort from
Iran for perhaps both of these men to be
relaying this same type of message at
the moment in Lebanon you have another
crisis going on it's unclear how much
exactly Hezbollah wants to ratchet up
tensions because Hezbollah is is
involved in trying to form a government
here this is a country that's on the
verge of bankruptcy this is a country
that has not had a government for quite
a while now and this is a very important
time in Lebanon where the prime
minister-designate is trying to put
together a cabinet and he cannot do so
unless he has Hezbollah's as support as
well because they are part of the major
political bloc here so this speech by
Hassan Nasrallah yes it did
threaten Americans but it did not go
into detailed specifically about how
exactly Lebanon would play a role in any
retaliation and because of that it
focused much more on a tox role in
expelling Americans I was going to ask
you exact Mohammad what was the
likelihood of Hezbollah retaliating for
Iran well that's the big question we had
expected to hear much more specificity
from mr. nasrallah about what exactly
might be happening in Lebanon that's
what a lot of analysts believed we might
be hearing today many of the Lebanese
the last few days they have been worried
that because of what happened 2000
Soleimani
and because of Iran's strong ties and
backing of Hezbollah that perhaps
retaliation could be seen against
Americans in Lebanon that perhaps
violence could be revisited upon Lebanon
and that's not something people want to
see happen here but also you have to
realize that Hezbollah is a bit boxed in
right now because of all the politics
going on right now because of the
fragile economy and Hezbollah cannot
really risk at this particular moment
getting into a wider regional or
international conflict at least that's
the conventional wisdom so many people
here at this hour believe that is why
mr. nasrallah perhaps did not focus so
much on what Lebanon specific role might
be in retaliation spoke more about the
region spoke more about aridif and Iran
and specifically spoke about the fact
that it would not be us civilians
targeted but it would be US military
assets targeted going forward thank you
for that Mommy jam June life or has seen
Beirut
now in an interview with Hezbollah
affiliated television channel Qasem
Soleimani said she has no doubt there'll
be retaliation for her father's death
how long ago could matter before
anything I'd like to send my greetings
to the supreme leader Ayatollah Ali
Khamenei and also to the leader of the
resistance uncle Hasan Nasrallah whom I
know for sure will avenge my father's
blood the entire world must know that
Qasim's assassination will not break us
and America must know that his blood is
so precious and we heard earlier from
Abbas masovia spokesman for Iran's
foreign ministry he says Iran isn't
pursuing war but is prepared for
anything
jamaat-e-islami done tamale jangan East
the Islamic Republic of Iran is not
pursuing war but we've made it very
clear that we're ready for any kind of
situation in the past decades the
Iranian nation has always been ready to
defend itself the decision will always
be made by the leadership and they will
prepare their responses as to how to
retaliate in the best way in the
meantime this is trying to avoid war now
US president Donald Trump has threatened
to hit dozens of targets inside Iran if
it takes any retaliatory action in a
series of tweets Trump said Iran would
be hit quote very fast and very hard if
attacks were launched against any
Americans or US assets iran's Foreign
Minister has responded saying targeting
cultural sites would be a war crime
Perico Haines is live for us in
Washington DC Perry let's start first
with this Iraq he votes in Parliament
calling for an end to US troops in to
the presence of foreign troops including
US troops what's the reaction likely to
be from Washington
well Secretary of State Mike Pompeo has
been making the rounds of the Sunday
political talk shows and he was pressed
on that by several different of the
anchors the host and he said well we
hope that doesn't happen we'll deal with
it if it does because this was all
happening as the boat was taking place
but he said that he believed the Iraqi
people really wanted the Americans there
this is going to go down in two separate
ways the president's going to be talking
to two very different audiences if in
fact US troops are told to leave Iraq
immediately first it's going to be his
core base he will probably do what he
tends to do in these situations is not
saying that this is a strategic setback
for the United States and its fight
against ISIL but he'll say look I
promise to get US troops out of the
Middle East and here they're coming home
the other audience that he had really
has to be concerned about at this point
our members of the US Senate let's put
this in the broader context this is a
president facing impeachment
he's already been impeached by the House
of Representatives we are probably just
weeks away possibly from an impeachment
trial in the Senate US senators are
going to realize the gravity of what
this will do to the US effort to fight
the Islamic State of Iraq and the Levant
that is not going to go over well but at
the same time there is growing concern
in the Senate in the house that the
president is literally bringing the
country to the brink of war with Iran so
that could also factor into the whole
impeachment discussion in a way that
perhaps the president doesn't want it to
patty president Trump on Saturday
threatened to hit 52 Iranian sites very
hard and very fast he said if Iran
retaliated and at the same time the US
administration says it wants to
negotiate and doesn't want regime change
in Iran you wonder what is the strategy
the Trump administration strategy here
well a secretary and pompay on these
shows that he was just talking on he
actually said that if any American
facilities or personnel are hit that the
US will respond by targeting the Iranian
personnel that planned the attack so
they're upping the threats even though
they're saying that they want to
de-escalate the situation right now the
president that we talking about 52 hits
for the different all of the Americans
that were held hostage decades and
decades ago that's getting overreaction
especially from Democrats who agree with
the Iranian Foreign Minister and they're
calling that a potential war crime there
has of course been discussion the US
military does have to follow the orders
of the commander-in-chief but in the
military code if they feel from eddie
commander an order is unlawful it is
their duty they are told to not carry it
out so this could be just more bluster
from president donald trump but there is
growing concern especially among
democrats that the intelligence that the
White House is giving them just doesn't
add up to basically what happened here
an assassination of a foreign leader
that the country is not technically a
warrant with we are going to see
movement this week the house the Senate
we expect that they're going to get full
classified intelligence briefings if
even some Republicans start to come out
and say there's not enough there there
to take this dramatic of a step
you could see movement on legislation
because although US presidents of recent
times they just take military action and
they don't really consult with Congress
technically in the Constitution Congress
has to declare war we've seen that
Democratic senators say he was going to
try and put a resolution on the floor
that says specifically the u.s. cannot
go to war with Iran now whether the
Republican leadership will actually let
that onto the floor remains to be seen
but this is going to be a critical week
because in this system it's supposed to
be equal branches of government so we'll
see if Congress wants to assert
themselves and be a check on this
president where they really haven't for
the last couple of decades when it comes
to presidents and armed conflict patty
we've heard the political reactions from
the Democrats or Republicans but what
about the wider American public how much
worry how much concern is there that
there could be a conflict with Iran well
and this is the problem for this
president he was elected in large part
because he'd said he's going to stop
these wars he's going to spend that
money here at home his base does not
want him to see a conflict another
conflict in the Middle East that said
these are these things can quickly
escalate when you start doing
tit-for-tat strikes I can't say that
there's been a whole lot of polling a
lot of that has to do with the calendar
it is the weekend here all of this was
happening over the Christmas holiday and
this tends to be a time if there's a
two-week period in time when Americans
tend to turn off the TV and stop reading
the newspaper it's right now so when
Congress comes back from their Christmas
break expect that they're gonna have a
lot more talk about it there's going to
be a lot more people tuning in then
they're gonna start to see the American
public opinion polls in general though
not about this specific issue the vast
majority of the American public in
previous polls before this has have said
they have no desire to see another
conflict in the Middle East thank you
for that Patty Cohan live for us in
Washington DC